Stack views are a new UI element.
Introduced in IOS 9 and
as the name suggests,
they make it easy to stack views.
You can have any UI view
sub-class inside a UI stack view.
In PagePerfect,
we're going to place our play back
buttons inside a set of stacked views.
Stack views can have either
a horizontal or vertical orientation.
You can control the alignment,
distribution and
spacing of a stack view.
Stack views can be nested
inside each other.
Here you can see a vertical
stack view for the entire screen
with horizontal stack views nested
inside for each row of buttons.
The real beauty in using stack
views is that you only need to
create our layout constraints for
the stack views.
What about all the UI elements
inside the stack view,
like are buttons in PagePerfect?
The stack views create their own
outer layout constraints for
all the UI elements contained in them
based on the alignment, distribution and
spacing settings you provide.
Let that sink in for a second.
Instead of having to create our layout
constraints for all these buttons
we can just embed them in UI stock
views and let them do the work.